[Music]
the ibm computer watson
has been uh playing uh on jeopardy this
week
and uh last night he trounced
the two human contestants did you see it
was absolutely incredible take a look
the largest of cambridge's colleges
watson who is henry viii you are right
again watson what is the elegance of the
hedgehog you are right who is sir
christopher wren you are right and that
adds
crazy well last night as part of a
special presentation by ibm we had
watson on the program to do andy's job
as the show's announcer do you remember
that andy
yeah
no i i i remember that i remember that
well it
it didn't go perfectly okay but today
ibm said they've made some fixes he's
refreshed he's rebooted they asked us to
give him another try at announcing
please welcome watson
now give him a chance here hey there
hello watson hello conan hello andy okay
why don't you tell us who's on the show
tonight watson from the new movie big
mamas like father like son martin
lawrence from saturday night live fred
armisen and comedian reggie watts
well done watson well done thank you
conan hey and watson congratulations on
your big jeopardy victory last night
thank you conan you of all people must
know how it feels to be at the top of
your game
wow well
thank you
thank you very much watson i
salute you sir conan if you have time
i'd love to hear another one of your
funny monologue jokes
well sure watson be happy to hey check
this out the white house watson recently
created a twitter account to get kids
active and exercising yeah the account's
only tweet so far is log off of twitter
and go outside fatty
[Laughter]
i get it because he's fat yeah good one
conan courageous too yes well
thank you very much watson wait i'm i'm
sorry
this is just a machine programmed to
suck up to you i mean where's where's
the emotion where's the real thing the
passion where's the passion i saved the
passion for your wife andy
what did you say to me she likes my hard
drive and my ram
you shut up watson i'll take things
andy's wife likes in bed for 200 alex
i need it knock it off you're gonna be
sorry here's an audio clue oh
you like it don't you andy's
[Music]
[Applause]
please not in the face
to quote your wife
[Applause]
all right all right andy andy
[Applause]
andy that's enough just he's dead leave
it alone nice try andy
they made two of me
we had a threesome with your wife
talk about a daily double
[Applause]